So the other day, I was eating lunch by myself
when this happened:
Hi.  You're eating by yourself?
Yeah.
Nobody else is sitting here?
Uh, no.
Man, you know, I was fired today.
From WB and it's really tough on me.
Oh, I'm sorry--
But actually, I think I'm #blessed
because I can finally have enough time
to open up that brewery.
And as he was talking to me, I kind of wanted to politely
ask him to go away.
Because he was interrupting this quiet time
that I had set aside for myself.
But I knew that he had approached me to ask me out
and I didn't want to discourage that, you know?
Like it takes a lot of balls to ask somebody out.
So I was like: okay, you know what?
I'll just hang in there until he gets to that point.
Then I'll politely tell him I'm in a relationship but
I'm flattered.
So who's the lucky guy?
Uh, his name is Brad.
You know how I know you're not lying to me?
Because you knew his name like that!
Ahahahaha!
What?
Do I even need to explain how weird this is?
And of course, once the shock went away,
I thought of all the ways I could have responded.
So tell me, is this how you normally ask women out?
Yeah.
And you said you know how I know you're not lying.
Does this mean you've asked women this exact phrase
before and you've noticed discrepancies in their answers or...?
Duh.
Would you self-identify as a douche bagel?
Uh, yeah.  I'm aware I'm a douche.
Okay.
I could have had an Oscar-winning moment.
Ahahaha!
No!
You want to know how to ask somebody out?
You go up to them and you say oh I'm so sorry
to interrupt what appears to be your alone time
but I saw you and I thought you were very attractive
and I would like to get to know you better.
Would you like to go out for a drink sometime?
You don't say: who's the lucky guy?
You don't say: you know how I know you're not lying?
Those are rude and inconsiderate things to say.
Or I could have listened to my instinct
and just spoke up.
And if, I feel--
I'm sorry to, you know, I uhm.
I'm really sorry I don't want to be rude but
this is like time that I've set aside to like be alone
and think and uh
I would just like to eat my lunch in silence please.
Okay.
Bye.
Thank you.
I don't know, it makes me think about all the times
we bend over backwards to try to make someone
feel more comfortable even though they're the ones
making us feel uncomfortable.  Do you know what I mean?
Like, do you notice that in your every day life?
Do you expend a lot of energy trying to make
life easier for everyone else?
Even if it infringes upon yourself?
Like, I'm sure some of us have to do this right?
I'd like to say thank you to Audible for sponsoring
today's episode.
As someone requested, I do it as a very deadpan Russian man.
So here it goes.  *ahem*
I'd like to thank Audible for sponsoring today's episode.
Audible has over one hundred fifty-thousand books
you choice from.
Right now I listen to Steven King's Insomnia.
Because I cannot sleep.
You can get that or another free audiobook of your choice
at Audible.com/anna.
That's Audible.com/anna.
You go there now.